we already know a lot of the fake givers
but one thing that occurs to me is that
one day I won't be making these videos
anymore
one day fake gurus will just be allowed
to start up and no one will be there to
call them out and so I want to leave a
guide to you for the people that I don't
cover how do you know whether someone's
a fake guru or not well I have ten red
flags just like theirs maybe red flags
on a date you know they they're rude to
the waiter you know red flag doesn't
mean it doesn't mean they're off the
table but if you have enough red flags
everyone knows you've enough red flags
you run for the hills so let me give you
my top ten list red flag number one
mastermind
[Music]
if they say mastermind at all come join
my mastermind red flag two cars they
have cars in their videos all the time
and they're always showing you their
wonderful cars and how they're just
living the life you're a Mike red flag I
mean you look at people like Warren
Buffett Bill Gates people like that do
they show off their wealth no they don't
need to show it off they got they got it
like that often times the people show it
off now rich [ __ ] got no money
now broke [ __ ] got no money sign me
behind it is so funny what's next
anybody who disparages real jobs and I
don't know about you guys but I know as
my job as an accountant it probably
would have taken me a hundred years to
save that much if for reasons why having
a nine-to-five job is actually high risk
and they start doing the thing we talked
about go to school and get a job right
so with that this was his lesson number
one and the rich don't work for money
red flag oh this one's huge
absolutely a massive red flag let me
invite you to my live webinar because
what basically all that tells you is
that they're lying because the live
webinar thing is a gimmick they're not
actually live there pre-recorded they're
like set up to look live
yes question good question sure the life
thing I can convert I can sell now you
automate it right now you can scale make
sense I don't know I don't live record
it I like that when anyone puts that
much time and effort into deceiving you
and making you think something that's
not actually true you have to be
wondering what else they're lying to you
about so red for red flag on that and a
lot of gurus do it ah like Dan Locke
does it John Kriss tani does it a lot of
those gurus do the live webinar thing
that's not really live it red flag paid
course huge red flag why is someone
who's a millionaire who has all this
money need to sell courses well red flag
does it mean that all paid courses are
scammed no no I feel like I have to
reiterate this a million times but just
the more red flags the worse off you are
this is a really good one younger than
35 I hesitated putting this in because
on the one hand I'm younger than 35 you
know I'm not trying to be ageist against
myself but let's put it this way to be a
coach you kinda have to have done it all
and most people under 35 just haven't
had enough life experience your life
barely starts until you're 20 so to say
that you need 10 or 15 years to really
know what you're doing in a field it's
not crazy to say like the two gurus I
like are like Gary Vee and Grant Cardone
the biggest reason for both of them is
that they have real businesses totally
outside of their guru ship and they're
both over 35 guys so they have a little
bit of years under their belt so you're
not a 20 year old listening to another
20 year old okay next one financial
history they make big
claims with very little evidence for
those claims I'm Brock Johnson I went
from zero to six million dollars in my
first six months I on Amazon show me the
money if anyone makes wild claims you
need some pretty wild evidence number
eight I'm just gonna say eight I don't
know if it's eight runs YouTube or
Facebook ads red flag next one free book
go get my free booklet bro
this is something called this is what's
called a lead funnel okay you go
let me explain real quick because this
is how fake gurus getcha they know cycle
how psychology works fake gurus are
geniuses with psychology so what they
know is that when you are given
something you're more likely to go and
buy the higher products so they give you
something for free with the idea that
number one now they're gonna have your
email info and they know you're already
interested in their product and number
two they're gonna go relentlessly pursue
your business and try to upsell you on
these crazy products final fake guru red
flag they endlessly talk about mentors
so do you need a mentor most successful
entrepreneurs today have Mentors Bill
Gates had ed Roberts Oprah Winfrey had
Mary Duncan Steve Jobs had Robert
Friedland Buffett had Benjamin Graham
Michael Jordan had Phil Jackson and I
can go on and on like of like people and
their mentors change the word mentor for
coach Albert Einstein one of the
smartest people in history had a mentor
he had a mentor his father at fifteen
and a half and mentors was mentored and
in turn he mentored other your
mentorship mentors mentors now there's
nothing wrong with a mentor and mentors
are good but oftentimes this language is
used to kind of pitch themselves as your
future mentor and when you tie this is
sort of a red flag that's tied with
another red flag which is if this if
they are talking all the time about
mentors and they offer a paid course red
flag they're trying to set themselves up
as your you know as your guru and tying
a bunch of money to it like I happen to
know that Dan lock has all his students
and seafood seafood seafood a and they
have to call him seafood when they're in
his court
first of all cringe second of all red
flag the guy is like playing some mind
games as soon as someone puts themselves
in a mentorship over you there they now
know what's best for you I would say
mentors are good but fine ones who are
not interested in profiting off you
right find them and those do exist out
there you know and it doesn't have to be
someone from the internet it can be
someone from your life
relative you know someone who knows you
well and just like you as a person but
the second people start attaching money
to this mentorship that's that's a red
flag so how do we how do we score the
red flags so here's what we're doing if
you have a one to two probably not a
fakie room you know I give them a path
at least investigate more if you have
let's say three to four use caution use
your best judgment be a little skeptical
five skepticism starts to kick in this
is where it's like uh and maybe you
don't even know about the other word
flat red flags yet but don't even
consider paying for anything very likely
that person's a fake guru six to nine
just run away just absolutely run away
do not don't even waste your time okay
any time you waste on their like sort of
things is just you're just falling into
their sales funnel I mean it's all just
a sales promoted and if they have ten
red flags red flags
send them send me an email cuz I want to
talk to talk to I really hope that helps
you navigate the world from now on if I
haven't talked about a fake guru just
run him through the system I like
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
Sakura
for the car
[Music]